so a little off topic here
but micah sometimes i go back and look
at old interviews when i'm prepping for
another one and our first one was for
your first feature
at any price and i know first features
can make a big impression on someone so
is there anything about your experience
working with ramin on that that you
still
find yourself thinking back to today oh
man absolutely i i feel like i learned
everything on that set
um it it changed
the course of my life you know right
right prior to to booking that job i was
kiteboarding professionally and um i was
on a completely different path
and i think if i didn't have such an
incredible experience
on that set um
i really don't know if i would have
continued to do it um
and what was so cool about that project
it was ramin's
first kind of nothing was a big movie
but but a bigger movie he had done some
shorts and smaller films
and so it's kind of both of us with like
zac efron and dennis quaid who have done
tons of movies because we're kind of
these like newbies being like
this is crazy so it's a really um
special
first experience that does not surprise
me at all he was
one of my first film professors so i
just hold him in the highest regard
because i don't think
so i know veena is a super collaborative
director
so for both of you here was there any
particular scene that you needed to
workshop with her
more than any other um i think within
all of the scenes
um it was just about having an open
dialogue about
what direction we were going to go in
and just like how far we could take it
with carl especially because i feel like
she gave me so many words and there was
like a lot
to say and chew on and it could go in a
lot of different ways so
in the rehearsal room it became
conversations about well
you know how far do you want me to go
with this do you want me to
like really just let it fly and be like
kind of over the top and lean into it or
do you want
it to be a more subtle thing and i think
ultimately what we arrived at is
we would have time to explore all the
different ways on set
but just for her to know and give me
permission to like
let it fly don't be afraid like this is
um
you know a character um
that that has a lot to chew him on
because he is a lot to chew on so don't
be afraid to go in that direction and i
can always reel you
in it was really intense i mean it was
you know for me
pretty much every scene every day um
night shoots a lot of takes of these
scenes
and so it was really nice to have um
[Music]
a person kind of like what dane was
saying like willing to really
push the boundaries and maybe we don't
use that take and maybe it's
it's not what is right for this thing
but but giving the space to be able to
like really
go there and see how that feels i love
finding out what a director's tell is
behind the monitor when you guys know
while you're doing a scene
that veena is really feeling a take so
is there anything she does that kind of
tells you like she's into this right now
i i don't know it seems like she would
get really excited i mean she's
she she wears her heart on her sleeve so
i feel like when she
um was really excited about a take you
could definitely tell
she's super into it you know i mean she
loves doing what she
she loves doing what she does and we
moved at a fairly
fast pace in making this so there was
never time to let up
you know um i'm a fairly
singularly minded person and i can't
really i certainly can't focus on like
multiple things
while i'm doing a take so i never got to
like peeper behind the monitor
when she like really was loving
something but she definitely always had
this energy of
you know moving forward and trying to
make it better and she always went in
there like with a note with an
idea ready to go on to the next take and
um i don't know that i i ever noticed
like
um a difference between when she was
into it and when she wasn't
with that singular mind frame on set
what was it like for you watching the
whole thing through for the very first
time was there anything that made you
say like holy [ __ ] that never even
registered for me on set
i mean i really loved watching it you
know i think i had a great time watching
it
um it was a lot of fun to shoot um
so i was definitely happy in viewing it
that like it's not just a thriller it's
not just
scary but um there's also it's also so
much
fun to watch you know i think there's
times that at least it makes me
laugh and i don't think i think it would
make anybody laugh and i think
you are scared but you also a lot of
times have a smile on your face and it's
really
a lot of ups and downs so i was
definitely happy that the joy that i
felt making it
um you know i i feel like the viewer has
a joy in watching it also
totally agree yeah not to like veer it
into the darkness now
but i'm always interested in hearing
about backstory and i don't know how
specific you get with your prep but did
you have to pinpoint
i guess i would say maybe the life event
that kind of
put carl on this path and got him
obsessed with the idea of playing god
with the algorithm
i didn't necessarily give him
like a life event that made him fall
into this i think it was just important
to know that like this wasn't his first
time doing it
um and he's been successful with it in
the past
and like that success has made him have
this like really god
complex where he feels like he's
invincible where he feels like he's got
it all figured out
um you know and i i don't even know that
um and i i i feel like those for those
reasons this was probably the first time
it really spiraled out of control
and he um you know he got as violent as
he gets
like i don't know that he's ever gotten
this violent in his experiments before
but i think while he's gotten this like
oh like basically i
am god i can predict people's behavior
mentality
that as it starts to slip he there's a
rage that builds up inside of him
you know and i i don't necessarily i
didn't necessarily pin point that down
to one event in his like past your life
or anything
spinning it around to end on a positive
note here you know we've been talking a
lot about
you know the negative effects of having
social media and technology in our lives
non-stop
what is one thing that both of you use
social media the internet you name it
for that i guess brightens your day
as an actor you know a fan base and
people that are coming to see your
movies is so important and so having a
way
to connect and kind of
show your i don't know that it
i don't know your normal life i don't
know it just it seems like a really kind
of cool way
to um
connect with people i guess that that
um are a fan and watching movies i mean
like i really love
looking at fan art you know um uh
it's cool and then i think it's a great
way to connect with fans
just to see that like oh i've made an
impact on their life and they're like
creating this thing and then tagging me
in it and i love looking at it for sure
um you know i also work a lot all around
the world so it's a great way
for me to keep in touch with all these
people i've worked with
um in italy and in south africa and
you know in like the arctic and like
just places
all around the world that i've worked
that i think it would be so hard to keep
in touch with them otherwise
you know i have like a driver named
cheslin that
he drove me on chronicle in cape town
south africa
like i don't know how long it was now
10-ish years ago
and um we still keep in contact and like
i still know what he's doing and like
without social media i don't think we'd
be able to do that
i love hearing that thank you guys for
hanging out for me with me
thanks great congratulations again thank
you so much